[音楽]
こんにちは私は
醤油を紹介する
醤油そごうレールです
醤油ソムリエル
初めて聞いた人が
ほとんどでしょう
胡散になった思った人もいると思います
商用紹介する活動を続けていたら
時代に
醤油ソングでと呼ばれるようになって
再生私もおこがましいし胡散臭いかもって
思っていたんですけれど
次第に
すっかり定着したのでそのまま肩書きにし
ています
そういうサムネイルは
寂しいことに何年経っても私一人しかい
ません
そういうは日本のご家庭に1本はあるの
でしょうが
あるのが当たり前すぎて
意識されにくいもの
仕方がないのかもしれません
それでも日本の一部には
正直を深みたい人
醤油を選びたい人
醤油の使い方をもっと知りたい人がいて
くれるおかげで
活動を続けることができています
なお私はその製造や販売をしておらずどこ
かどっち企業と契約していることもないの
で
売り込みはしないですよ
ご安心ください
では何をしているのかそれは
選び使うお手伝いいい醤油良い醤油に同じ
よう
未来につなげることが目標です
今そういう蔵など日本の
感動する手仕事は
次々と減り続けています
それであればいいトートを押さえ方にし
たいそう思っています
では私はなぜこの活動を始めたのでしょう
か
少し
頭を18年前にタイムスリップしてみ
ましょう
当時の私はある芸術大学に通う大学3回生
課題の関連で
地元を調べています
実は私の地元小豆島の南東部は小医療が
盛ん
当時私の家の周りにはお茶屋さんが16件
繋がっていて
地元を調べることは
商用調べることになりました
地元の醤油作りの最大の特徴は
記憶仕込み醤油という醤油の
代表サービスであること
清き仕組み醤油とはこのような
木製の木置きに仕込んで作る
伝統的な醤油です
この日よけ仕込み醤油の3分の1から4分
の1が小豆島で作られています
大量生産型の仕込み容器は
場所を一問わず
正確輸送すれば
80点くらいの融資の醤油を安定生産し
やすいのに対し
表記事故物証意はバラエティ豊か
蔵や桶椅子無数の菌がどのようにしたら
良い働きをするのか
蔵人は
自分なりの答えを探し
信じながら作ります
蔵人の日々の姿勢が現れやすく
愛がないクラブとか作るそういうそれなり
に
愛がある蔵人が作る醤油はそのクラブトラ
らしいおいしさになります
繰り返しになりますが
当時の私は
原始大学に通っています
アートと醤油は一見関係ないように思い
ますが
真剣表現活動を行っていたからこそ
松を作る人々に
強い感銘をきました
愛がある比べたは
誇り高いクリエイターで
相違はまさに作品だと
そしてその作品を
難しいこと抜きに
楽しむことができる
いいものを作っているかっこいい
これまでは近所のおっちゃんとしか思って
いなかった蔵人たちに
心速掘れましたそして言いました
素晴らしいですこれからもぜひ続けて
くださいと
すると思いがけない言葉が返ってきました
脳から
続けるのは難しい
彼らいいものを作っているし日本人にとっ
て醤油は重なるそれでも現実は厳しいのか
と驚きましたそして
同時に気づきましたこれは
醤油だけの問題ではないと
地元のお店や伝統工芸
野菜や魚用お肉
郷土料理
美しい景色
祭り事いろんなものが消えようとすること
に
日本だからこの地域だからこの人だから
こそできる
誇らしいことが
消え続けていると
ではなぜ
いろんな人にリサーチし
答えが見えてきました
意識されていないからだ
選びたい人がいても
選ぶ方法がないからだと
伝えなければ
以来私は
スクリプト使い手をつなぐ仕事を続けてい
ます時には多分やを通して力を合わせ
ながら
100年後の
孫やひ孫に
良い選択肢を残すために
このような
会議名簿を胸に刻み
活動を続けること18年
その間
ひたすら全国地の倉本を巡り
手に入れた醤油の
プロの皆さんと一緒に分析し
料理に使い
伝えてきました
しかし
活動を始めて34年ほど経った時
ふとあれと気づいたことがあります
社会のためミラーのためって言ってるけど
も一番
恩恵を受けてるのは私ではと
この活動を始めてから年齢や地域業種の壁
を置いて
素晴らしい方々にたっくさん出会うことが
できました今日みたいに
特に
醤油は単体では料理ができないので
他の調味料です食材にも興味を持つように
なりそこから一気に社会が見え何気ない
景色はどんどん輝いていく
まるで
愛知が宝探しのようでした
しかも
毎日を食卓も
豊かになって
味わい深い
[音楽]
当たり前でやってなくてはならない存在だ
なと思いますね
[音楽]
美味しそうだねじゃあね
はいじゃなくいただきます
[音楽]
上がる人
美味しい
[音楽]
あの農家探すと野菜や
朝
魚屋さんが一押ししていた地魚で今日は何
作ろう
今日はこの醤油とアナベリンで炊いて
みよう
近所のおっちゃんから柑橘言ったのだから
ポン酢でドレッシングしておこう
ナイスのご飯準備って
面倒になりがちですよね1日3回もあり
ますし
でも
面倒な紙一重のところに楽しいがあります
だから私は私自身が楽しくなるよう心がけ
ています
そして私の周りの人たちはみんな
ご飯作りを大人がちょこっと
楽しむチャンスにしています
ちょこっとした遊びとは
醤油レースすると
例えばこんな感じ
例えば
薄口醤油で刺身を食べてみるとか
兵庫県のカフェで愛用されている醤油です
ね
刺身には
濃厚なアウトされがちですが一概には言い
ません
例えば
火になるタイヤヒラメもしくは
濃厚なウニやサーモンを
薄く醤油で味わうと
足のバランスが取れて
素材の持ち合い時は生きて
美味しいんですよこれの刺身は個人的な
濃厚で味わうよりも好きです
あとこれから
汗をかくような日には
普段
保育師匠で作るような料理
例えば
炒め物とか冷ややこう
薄くしょいで味わうと
味わいがさっぱりとするし
足を掻くと
体が塩分を干して
美しい方が
美味しく感じやすいです
他にも普段使っていない処理を使ってみる
とか
例えば
美しそうな真逆の
再仕込み醤油という濃厚な醤油を1本持っ
ていくと
足の幅が広がります
特に
料理はあんましない人におすすめです
例えば
卵ご飯や冷奴はもちろんのこと
レトルトのカレーやミートソースにかける
と
味わいが濃厚になって満足度が高まります
もし味付けが面倒であればいっそスーホの
醤油並べておいて
好みの醤油で味わってもらったらいい
慣れや体調賢いによってあれこれ言われる
ぐらいやったら
味付けはまかしちゃいましょう
壮大だってそういうのの調味料やスパイス
をかけてアレンジすれば思いがけない
うるさいなりますし
彼の調味料も
案外にあるもんで簡単に作れます
最後に一応するのは人の顔や
楽しい思い出を呼び起こすような
食材調味を使うこと
そういうぐらいなど生産現場を訪ねたりお
店の人とおしゃべりしながら買うと
料理を作る時も
心がバクバクするし
作った料理も
美味しく感じやすいものです
なぜ
遊ぶことを進めているのか
遊んで
心がワクワクとすると
芋づる式に
面白い楽しいが
次々出てくるからそして
社会や未来も面白くなるから
これは理想論ではなく
芸術の話です
例えば
商用楽しみ始める人の多くは
清木仕込み醤油を試します
清記事組書はバラエティ豊かな上に
グリテのこだわりが伝わりやすくて
使っていて
ワクワクするのです
同時に
塩気軸の書を作る倉本を盛り上がり始め
途絶える寸前だった
供給を作る
職人さんたちも
全国地に新たに出てきて
倫理業まで盛り上がりなんと数十年ぶりに
記憶用の木材の植林が
再開されることになったんです
これまでは大量生産をされて
減り続け
きようとして気をつけ自己未勝利が増え
始めのないのかなって
リアルに関しています
このようにあらゆる食材を調味料が
多くの社会や文化につながっています
私たちの日常が
未来を作ります
その証拠に
過去があります
例えばこの木置きは100年以上前に作ら
れたものそしてこの記憶の木は
さらに100年以上前に植えられたもの
この木を植えた人は
自分の収入のために植えたのではない
100年後に伐採して手渡しする子孫の
ためそして200年後の今の私たちが
美味しいと感じるにはこの木が必要だと
思ったから
清木塾の人を一つでも
林業の人お化粧に
家事や
農家蔵人これまで使ってきた人たっくさん
の人々の日常の上にできています
想像を超える思いったわざと時間を
口にしているのです
今は
多くのものを簡単に手に入ることができる
がゆえに時間軸や
周りが見えにくくなっています
だから
短期間で使えなくなるものを快活だし
環境に悪くても気になりにくい
仕方がないことだと思います
しかし
買うという行為は
未来何を残すのかという一挙を通してと
同じです
人口減少が進みます
多くの物事がどんどん消え続けています
無意識や無関心で買うのか
選ぶという意識の下で買うの中で
未来のこれまでは変わります
トータは必ず起きるそれであれば
未来何を残すのか
選んで問うとさせませんか
とはいえどうしたらいいのかわからない
でしょうし
理性だけでは続かないもの
だからまずは遊びましょう
遊べば考えるきっかけになります
無意識だったものを
意識できたら大きな一歩
そこから何を買うか
意識すれば
名古屋ひ孫は
毎日面白いて感じるような未来を見てみ
たいならまずは皆さんから今日から
答申を
日本の感動や誇りそして
面白そう
未来につなげましょう
ありがとうございます
[拍手]